dr fellows caelers this chair in the
pepers the caruso life where many of you
herschel richard de word en emoji
was prefer studies and mooji fingers dat
art and i made it in real time and react
to live show gestures this is implemented
in the new iphone phones
however to accomplish this it uses dat
project there to get good in of
understanding of the geometry of
erasing face techniques that doesn't
need any special pet
take that i feel with live
photographic input and create digital
avatar of  as that can be and imitates in
real time where time i had never look at
this incredible results as you can see
the final result of sling [ __ ]
who drink your components like a skis and
then now that avatar was on that
foil photorealistic
with heft to  capture the appearance and
gestures of the user
well enough so they can be used in video
games or any telepresence application
where self users' interact in a virtual
world
and so b  oos then manny prior works the
lord is not reconstructed streng bystram
lucas doing this in real-time is not
feasible also note that the information
wiardi van is highly incomplete peak is
the backside of the skin is not catcher
it is characters also have quite
appropriately king  hairstyler
zo hou is so even possible while first
segments the input emoji in by the
phase bart and de herbert
then the hair parties which you and your
network that tries to extract attributes
leg length spy knowledge order hermans is
die je pony tl
where the high line  is and more this is an
extremely deep neural network good over
fifty layers and it took for details and
images of different hairstyles tutoring
well since it is highly unlikely that the
input pictures shows a man for the fall
out that was never ever worn by any
money  as weekend also in thor big data
set of four adr system hairstyle and
choose the closed one that fits the
attributes expected but then you're not
work such smart idea
loving it you can see how well this
works in practice and in the next up de
movement en de pier
rens of de final its geometry can be
computer in real-time floor en navel pro
league en al reepe representation de
technique also supports mee targeting
which  means that all gestures can be
transferred to the van characters
de framework is also very robust to the
faint light and conditions which means
that de die family photographer we lead
to face i müller appel
de same applies for expressions this is
one of two highly desirable details  that
make sure breaks the usability of a zero
technology introduction and true human being and
this one test with flying colors
in this campus if you can already see that
the quality of the switches as if smokes the
competition
variant of the technology can be
downloaded free de link  in the video
description tag for watching and folio
generous support na see you next time
[Music]